Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I am Robert
Krulwich today on radio lab blame
in the story we just heard, Lee, we're
wrestling with a very difficult question.
When somebody has a brain
injury, then commits a crime.
Just how much do we blame them and
how much do we blame the brain?
Yeah, and as it turns out, this
question, hi. Hi, this is Chad. Hi Chad.
It's Nita.
That question is popping up more and
more in court cases were increasingly,
you will find defendants
like Kevin Arguing, okay,
you've convicted me of a crime,
but you should go easier on me because
I have these neurological problems.
So this is neat.
A fairy honney professor of law and
philosophy and professor of genome
scientists and policy at Duke University.
She's been following this whole sort of
emerging field of neuro law for quite a
while. And back in 2006
it occurred to her, okay,
lots of people are interested in this
field, but nobody has any good data.
So I started counting cases, try to see,
to try to see how many times does
brain science come up in court. Now,
the only data that she'd get her
hands on were written opinions,
which turns out it
doesn't happen that often.
Like yours really only happens
in like 1% of court cases, but,
but in that 1% of cases she saw
a steady increase and you know,
relatively dramatic. You,
you have a couple of years,
2005 and six that had about a hundred
cases in (200) 078-9200 some cases.
And then 1112 year in the three hundreds
all told between 2005 and 2012 it's
about 1600 cases at 1600 cases that
are kind of like the Kevin Case where
someone maybe argues, look, it's not
entirely my fault. My brain made me do it
at least a little bit.
Yeah. And by the way,
that number was just in
the 1% she had access to.
So the other 99% of cases may
actually have a whole lot more. Yup.
Well, wait a second. Is this a new
development? What do you mean? Like,
you know, in west side story,
there's this character officer crunchy
and he goes and there's these juvenile
delinquents.
This is back in the 50s and they're
saying everything is someone else's fault.
So they have bad parents and they have
poverty and they have passion and they
have [inaudible]
youth and they plead all these kinds of
Sargent crop geek yet gotta understand
it's just our bringing up that gets us
Outta hand. Our mothers solid junkies,
our fathers all are.
Have you just added to the list tumor?
That's pretty much the same thing.
Well maybe, no,
there seems to be something
more compelling for both
judges and juries when you
are able to have actual
brain scans, you know,
or EEG or whatever because now you can
say, look to officer Crunchy, look,
I know this might sound like an excuse,
but check out this spot right here.
Here's the proof. I don't
have a normal brain, you know,
and I didn't choose not
to have a normal brain.
So how can it be
completely my fault? Well,
doesn't that sound a little bit like
a little too easy? Here we go. Maybe.
I mean, I guess it depends on the
specific case, but just in the abstract.
Let me give you the version that
I've ever heard of this argument.
This is what made me really stop
and take. It comes from the, uh,
from my psychologist Kevin Dutton.
He was interviewed on the scientific
American podcasts and he gave this
hypothetical.
I imagine if you've got
a deaf person, okay,
and you've got a child in a
burning building and you've
got that child screaming
out, but the deaf person
can't hear the screams to,
you wouldn't necessarily blame.
You wouldn't hold that deaf
person culpable for that
child's death if the child
died you nuclear. So
far. By the same token,
if you are emotionally death, if
you can physically hear the screams,
but emotionally you just don't have that
kind of neural kick up the backside to
go in and save that child.
Isn't that the same thing?
And when you start thinking about that
as a whole kind of moral conundrum that
starts coming out of that,
because damage to the ear is
damaged with physical structure,
damage to the brain is also damaged
physical structure. So here's the moral
conundrum I think he's referring to.
If we go along with this idea that we
can use brain abnormalities to defend
ourselves in court.
Well that's going to lead us into
some pretty weird places as a society,
things may get very, very
complicated cause we learned,
we got into a little tussle.
All right with this guy,
sorry, so you put this on. This
is a little chilly in here.
This is David Eagleman.
I'm a neuroscientist. He's
a regular on our show.
Is that what I supposed to say or
that spirited regularly? Yeah. No.
Here's one of the most interesting parts.
Here's his argument. Think about it.
Technologically at the moment,
our best technologies in
neuroscience are very crude.
We can see when someone has a tumor or
damage from traumatic brain injury or
neurodegenerative disease, but it is
quite crude still. The way he puts it.
Looking for those brain abnormalities
now is sort of like being up in space and
looking down at the earth. You can't
really see what's going on down there,
but you can see the big shapes and the
colors and every so often you notice
something that's not supposed
to be there. Like, Whoa,
what does that creator over there?
If you see something that's big
enough to see you take a picture,
you're back in court,
you show it to the judge and
maybe she gives the guy a break,
but then say you're up there and
um, mission control, everything
looks normal up here.
You don't see anything.
Well then back in court,
the judge is going to take a look at
your apparently normal brain and say,
sorry, well that's your fault.
It's not a biological problem.
So we're just going to say you're
blameworthy. So that's where we are now.
We draw the line of what we can see and
what we can see is only the big stuff.
But he says, imagine forward,
we'll have new technologies,
we'll have x MRI instead fri and suddenly
it's going to be like Google maps
where instead of being
up in space, you can,
you can zoom in and now
you can see everything.
We'll have new names for disorders
of the microcircuitry and so on.
We'll certainly never get
all the way to the end,
but one day we may be able to say like
see that little bit of mangled wiring
right over there. That is because
his mom didn't love him enough.
Maybe he got bullied like we will be
able to see all that stuff almost as well
as we can see brain tumors now cause there
is nothing special about brain tumors
except for their visibility. Really what
he's saying when you get down to it,
his core belief is that you
are your biology which is
on some level kind of like
whatever, Duh, but he
takes it much farther.
He says that almost everything
that you go through in your life,
all of your experiences, your culture,
your history, your neighborhood,
all of it is etched into the
tissue of your brain, right?
There's nothing separate. Nothing.
Descartes famously suggested you've got
the body, you know the physical stuff,
and then you've got this extra bit,
the sole, the ghost in the machine.
[inaudible]
but sort of the, you know the inside
word on that neuroscience is that ag? No,
no, no. It's all the same thing.
And now that we're beginning to
see that, he says, actually see it,
we are on a slippery slope because if you
start letting people off the hook when
you see a tumor,
well then you're going to have
to keep letting him off the hook.
When you see something smaller
or smaller or smaller, still
the point is it cannot be a just
legal system that in one decade says,
well you're blame worthy cause for the
moment we can't see anything in your
brain. And then the next decades is,
oh, you have SJ medleys disease. Hey,
we can see it now. And
we didn't realize that.
So now you were lumping you over here
with the people with the brain tumors.
So they want, does that mean like we
have to let everybody off the hook?
You know, blame worthiness is the wrong
question for a legal system to ask.
That's the point is that this whole
notion about blame worthiness and saying,
okay,
if we have a biological mitigator then
we'll bring that up in court and we'll
say, well,
it's not exactly his fault and if we
don't have a biological mitigator,
we'll say it is his fault.
The reason none of this makes sense
nowadays is because saying was it the
person's fault or was it something about
his biology doesn't make sense as a
question. They are inseparable. Why I
got, I have a version of that question.
How about everybody should know that his
brain isn't completely normal in this
regard. And now the
question is proportion,
how much do you want to put on the brain
and how much do you want to put on his
and what else is there behavior which
comes from where ability to choose from
the brain is choosy part of his brain
as the most [inaudible] and choosy part.
Well that's okay. I don't, I
mean you're forcing me. I'm glad.
I'm glad you're phrasing
it this way because that's
exactly the problem with our
intuitions. We have this intuition that
yeah, your brain might look like this.
You have these genes,
you have these experiences that
makes your biology like this. Oh,
but in the end,
that doesn't matter because you've got
this other thing that's independent of
the biology, but we don't. You
aren't your brain, your brain,
however nevertheless helps you decide
things. Brains help you choose.
So the question I'm asking
you that they're helping,
who's the you that you're
helping the bearer of the brain,
the owner of the brain, the the, the
brain. And that's separate from the brain.
Oh, do you own, I need
to keep doing this to me.
I know that if I have a tootsie
roll in front of me in an m and, m,
I can choose the M and m.
So I assume my is doing something and
the question I want to ask is like how
much am I choosing and how much
am I really outside of choosing?
Because some something irregular
in my brain is choosing for me.
And that seems to me to
be a way to, so, so this,
but this is fascinating because the
way you're phrasing it suggests that
there's, um,
there's you and then there's your brain
and there's things in your brain that
might be telling you what
you don't want to do,
but it's all one system is the thing.
So when you're faced with the tootsie
roll versus the whatever else, m and m,
every thing in your life leading up to
that moment from your genetic history
written on invisibly small
strands of nucleic acids,
all the way up to every experience
you've ever had leads to that choice.
What would it even mean to make a choice?
Completely independent of your brain.
Okay. [inaudible]
what about like the 10 Commandments? Those
are like the, those were, those were,
okay. I'm just gonna jump in
for a second. At this point,
things kind of slid off the rails.
We ended up talking about
the 10 commandments,
debating the question of freewill
if free will exists at all.
It's a really small part of this system.
I'm going back and forth about whether
you can overcome your upbringing,
which obviously you can. Oh Gosh, no, you
can't share. You can't. No, you can't.
I can go to the library and I, it's only
if you're that type of person. Anyhow,
after an hour, we finally got
back around to David's main point,
which is that the legal system would be
a hell of a lot better off. He says, if,
uh, if we forgot about blame altogether,
forget if it's someone's fault.
That's a dead end. He would
say the better way to do it,
he thinks is to focus on this
probability of future recidivism.
You mean like will they do it again?
That's right. That's exactly it. Well,
how would you ever know? So
here's how you crunch the numbers.
So this has already happened in the world
of sex offenders where there've been a
longterm studies following out. Here's
the way it already works. He says,
which he thinks is model. When a
sex offender comes up for parole,
someone at the corrections office will
grab their record and ask a bunch of
questions. What was the victim choice?
Was it somebody they knew or was it
somebody outside of their family?
Was it a a minor, specific to male
or female? Was it somebody their age?
What was the crime type? All
these different questions.
Then the evaluator will take some
of the answers and give them points.
Three zero two that psychologist
Amy Phoenix, she says,
researchers developed this point system
based on years of studies of criminal
behavior, massive amounts of data and
once you have all these points down,
you can add up a total score and that
score is supposed to tell you is this guy
likely to do it again or not? And
here's the bottom line. Amy says,
if you were to ask a parole officer with
decades of experience to just use their
gut, no numbers, we call that
unguided clinical judgment.
If you were to ask them for their
unguided, but expert clinical judgment,
will Fred here recidivate or not? What's
your prediction? According to studies,
those experts are correct
about 50% of the time,
so you may as well flip a
coin. On the other hand,
she says if you have just use the
point system, no gut involved,
the predictive accuracy would be about 70%
wow. 70 years and no humans involved.
Yeah. But here's the thing
that sort of gives me pause.
Like in order to get that accurate,
you kind of have to turn people into
data, you know? Yeah. Into types.
I know it seems like, Oh, where's
the humanity in that? But,
but the question we have to
ask is, compared to what?
So the way it currently goes,
ugly people get much longer sentences
than attractive people in courts.
This is a well known bias from juries.
Is that somehow better than having a
scientifically informed legal system?
I have no response to that. Well,
but elaborate Willie [inaudible]
yes.
It's okay that pretty people get better
sentences than ugly people because I'm,
I don't know, I'm going out on the limb,
see what happens when I
finished this in one go.
But because what we're describing
here is humans judging humans,
not tables judging humans, not data
judging humans, but humans judging humans.
So you went to do that with certain amount
of humanness and maybe it's not very
rational and maybe sometimes
it's wrong-headed or unfair,
but if you take the judgment away from
the humans and you give it to a table,
then you invite a different set of
problems, which is the chance for mercy,
which is a very big part of justice is
off the table because statistics don't
have mercy. They just have statistics.
Amen. I that was nicely done,
but let me say, let me see,
Campbell, the question that,
that is a beautiful question. So the
notion of we should be merciful and so on.
Of course, that's all true. But
the question is, are we good at it?
Are we good at knowing who is the
right person to be merciful with?
It ends up usually being the
attractive person, right?
And the person who's ugly
in his missing teeth,
we're usually not as merciful
for, I wish this morning.
Let me just throw in one
more objection to this. Uh,
I mean obviously as a point, I guess.
So this whole thing that he's advocating
for and he's not the only one of
throwing out blame, focusing
instead on what someone might do.
Is that a world you would want to
really live in, need a fair honey,
that law professor, put it this
way, imagine you do something small.
So if I, you know, forge a check,
minor offense and in the process
of arresting me and convicting me,
maybe the courts do a brain scan or
they do that number crunching thing.
Exactly. And they determine,
actually she has a predilection for far
more serious crimes than check forging.
I mean, she hasn't done any of those
things yet, but she could rob a bank,
she could commit a violent crime.
That's what the data shows.
If all you're worried
about is what she might do,
then you can keep me in
prison forever. Because, um,
what you've discovered is that I pose
a real and future danger to society.
I mean, you could basically
convict someone of a crime
that hasn't happened yet.
Exactly. And not only that,
if you think about this whole thing
from a slightly higher altitude,
according to Anita, when you
blame somebody for something,
there's a power to that act that
goes beyond that one individual.
There is value to society holding people
morally accountable for wrongdoing.
Your you're upholding this code
that is important to all of us.
It's what we've lived by and clung
to for thousands of years. Yeah,
so you could argue that the
act of assigning blame is
sort of like reinforcing
the scaffolding of society. It
creates norms for people to follow.
That makes perfect sense to
me. Otherwise we would be,
well, it'd be like, I
don't know what we'd be
[inaudible]
so hey, so you're coming out for the
10 commandments at the end of the day.
Wait, hold on. No shot.
Let's just say he went there
and he can't take it back.
Don't draft me onto that team. By the way,
speaking about us. Not
that we were, but now I am.
We are going to be on stage in 21
cities in the United States and Canada.
We're just about to start our live
tour. The show is called apocalyptical,
which is a lot of syllables,
but it's a, it can be fun.
It's got a lot of performances. Yes.
Check our listings at radiolab.org/live
you'll see where we are and when we're
going to be there. And you can
get your tickets now. Yeah.
radiolab.org/live and we'll be right back.
Uh.